hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible attacking game from the
Champions Chester chessel Masters 2024
the winners bracket Grand final two it
is leevon arunan versus Vincent kimer
and this is the final game of their
match Vincent won the first one and now
leevon needs to bonds back with the
white pieces in order to force further
tie breaks so let's see what happened
here and uh who won division two of this
prestigious event now leavon with the
white pieces opens with Pawn to E4 and
uh some you know a couple of years back
you would think okay what would someone
like Vincent even be doing playing
against leevon but nowadays on the live
ratings list uh Vincent is actually
world number 17 and leevon is world
number 25 but still if leevon has a good
day with the white pieces no one stands
a chance with black uh so let's see if
he had a good day we have E4 Pawn to E5
Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and bsh sorry
Knight to C6 Bishop to C4 uh the Italian
game is on the board and now Knight to
F6 the two knights defense and not
everyone's favorite but D3 uh the
so-called modern Bishop's opening we
have Bishop to C5 uh and castles we have
Pawn to A6 C3 and Bishop to A7 the line
we have pretty much every other video as
it's very popular Bishop to B3 Pawn to
D6 we have Rook to E1 and now kingside
castles uh again I will repeat if Knight
to G4 going after the F2 Pawn white will
just play Rook E2 defend the F2 Pawn
kick away the Knight and the Rook will
actually be very nicely placed on E2
later on you can easily double up with
Rook a to E1 uh in case you were
wondering so castles we have Knight B to
D2 Pawn to H6 and now Knight to F1 all
standard Maneuvers nothing new here
Bishop to E6 now you could tuck the
bishop back to C2 for later use but here
uh leevon goes for a trade we have
Bishop captures F captures and Bishop to
E3 uh also offers a trade of dark Square
Bishops with Vincent captures we have
Bishop captures but now not F captures
or Knight captures but Rook captures on
E3 and there are a couple of games Queen
to D7 is a know move Knight to E7 is a
know move but Vincent goes for the
immediate Pawn to D5 and it is now as of
move 13 that we have a completely new
game uh and okay Queen to B3 putting
pressure on the B7 Pawn also very nice
as you might have some uh future uh
possible action against the black king
along this diagonal so Queen to D6 uh
asking Leon are you maybe interested in
a nice juicy Pawn but of course if
leevon captures the pawn then Vincent
traps his Queen so of course he's not
going to do that he plays Rook a A1 uh
the idea behind Rook 8 to E1 is that
leavon wants to capture on D5 and then
he just wants to expose the E5 pawn and
win some material the problem is Vincent
plays Pawn to D4 and look at what
happens here C captures on D4 e captures
attacking the rook and okay Rook goes
back and now Knight to H5 and with this
D4 Pawn clamping down White's entire
position it's very hard for want to find
any uh any use for those Rooks probably
shifting them over to the C file trying
to maybe you know uh prevent the knight
from from moving uh as the C7 Pawn is
weak uh and that's exactly what he does
Rook to C2 uh and now Vincent could
continue in a lot of ways he could
continue with something like uh well
Knight to B4 he could go after the rook
and then play Pawn to C5 to cement that
D4 Pawn he could go for Knight the A5 to
attack the White Queen here uh but he
goes for Rook captures on F3 and this is
a this is a sensational um uh exchange
sacrifice because uh well it's just
incredibly complicated to defend this
attack to give you an example if you
capture The Rook then comes Knight E5
and okay Knight captures on F3 is the
threat and after you stop that let's say
you play anything let's say Knight D2
defend the pawn then Knight comes to F4
you're going to attack this Pawn now
this Pawn cannot be defended and you can
win this game whichever way you prefer
you can go for the king side attack you
can just play C5 B5 C4 and completely uh
you know uh crush your opponent with
with some positional play uh this is
dead lost so instead leavon plays the
only move that keeps him in the game and
that is Queen captures on B7 attacks the
rook and attacks the Knight here and now
it's a pretty crazy position and you
could uh probably you know think of a
couple of good moves but what would be
the best move here you know just you
don't need to pause the video maybe just
you know give or even pause it you know
give the position some thought what
would you play here with
black yeah so here with black uh you
play Knight to B4 it's it's a really
beautiful move that uh allows Leon to
capture The Rook with check and also uh
you could capture this rook and also
your Rook on C2 is hanging so what can
you do you can't really capture The Rook
on A8 because if you capture that then
Vincent had the idea of Rook to f8
attacking the queen and once the queen
moves just picking up the Rook on C2 and
of course completely winning so Leon
again plays the only uh playable move G
captures on F3 so he doesn't take the
the so-called free rook and now again
this uh position where uh unless you
find the only move Leon will just
completely Crush you uh again feel free
to pause the video and continue the
attack for Vincent you know well I'll
give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on having incredible
board Vision And for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Queen
back to f8 look at this weird move Queen
back to f8 defends The Rook defends the
Knight keeps the C2 Rook um uh under
attack and also puts pressure on the on
the F3 Pawn you can later on REM
maneuver the queen to F6 to F4 go for
the king side attack uh this move just
does everything and leavon still has to
react to his Rook being under attack now
you could maybe move it back to to D2 to
guard the D3 Pawn H but I mean that just
looks incredibly passive so leavon goes
for Rook captures on C7 and it is the
absolute best move uh putting pressure
on that G7 Pawn uh so what do you play
here well again you have to be precise
Rook to B8 attacks the queen and after
Queen to A7 going after the D4 Pawn now
comes Knight captures on D3 attacking
The Rook on E1 so okay Rook to D1 and
now Knight to E5 also Knight to F4 is
very nice the Vincent goes for Knight to
E5 and now Rook D to C1 doubling up on
the C file and here we have King to H7
now uh how do you continue this with
white well uh objectively the position
is still playable and it's a draw but
leevon had over five minutes on the
clock and Vincent had one minute on the
clock as it's a rapid game and here
leavon played Queen to C5 he offered a
queen thread I'm just going to show you
how complicated the position is and how
uh uh you should play it in order to
actually save this game you have to play
Knight to G3 which is just a weird move
to play because your F3 Pawn is hanging
here and uh well you it it's impossible
to calculate for example Knight captures
on F3 King G2 Knight Capt Knight H4
check King to F1 now and queen to F3 uh
but uh turns out there's no Checkmate
here Queen captures on B8 and that's
pretty much it Knight captures and G3 H
captures and queen to H1 check and you
would have to settle for a Perpetual
here uh you can't go to to D1 otherwise
Queen D3 check followed by Knight to F3
Checkmate so I go back and here we would
have a Perpetual checking sequence and
the game would end in a draw uh only one
of the lines that end in a draw but I I
I chose the nicest one to show you but
here leavon played Queen to C5 and now
Vincent plays Queen to F6 it's a very
nice um counter to Queen to C5 it just
defends the Knight here and uh prepares
um to start an attack against the white
king also Al I will show a very nice
line with Queen to F4 uh Queen to F4 is
uh only a little bit better because with
Queen to F6 you allow the leev maybe
Queen to E7 will be sort of a stubborn
defense it's still winning for black but
very hard to win but just to give you uh
you know an idea of how our uh silicon
overlords do it uh Queen to F4 and after
Knight to G3 Rook to B5 only winning
move but it is uh very very impressive
uh later on you will uh you know shift
to the once the queen moves you will
capture on F3 will bring the Rook into
the attack and that's pretty much it but
okay uh wincent uh after this queen to
C5 move went Queen to F6 again
objectively winning uh and now Knight to
G3 uh like I said the only way to maybe
punish this queen to F6 move a little
bit is to go Queen to E7 uh but then
again after Knight captures on F3 King
to H1 and queen to G6 going for
checkmate here you will have to play
Knight G3 for example captures captures
and there's still more work to be done
here it's not the game over like in the
previous line you will have to rely on
your past D pawn and some other
resources but okay after Queen F6 Knight
to G3 and now Knight captures on F3 with
check and now King to H1 much better
than King to G2 if you go King G2 then
look at this Knight to F4 check uh and
that's uh it wherever you go uh you
can't really do anything if you go uh if
you go back for example with King to H1
uh there's even Rook captur on B2 then
you're going to have to worry about Rook
captur F to Rook captures on H2
Checkmate and of course if you capture
the Knight then Knight to D3 a nice
Discovery picks up the White Queen on C5
uh so instead after Knight captures King
to H1 by Leon and now Knight to E5
getting ready to finish the attack uh we
have Knight captures on H5 eliminating
one of the attackers and now one last
precise um uh move order by Vincent
Queen F3 check not of course going after
the Knight right away King to G1 and now
Queen captures on H5 we have Pawn to H3
and now Rook captures on B2 uh Queen to
E7 there is no nothing you can do here
leavon threatens Checkmate but it's all
over Queen to G6 with check King to F1
and now Knight to D3 and he was in this
position un move 32 that leevon Aran
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh whatever you
play Rook captures an F2 Checkmate there
is no way to uh play any move that will
sort of keep you in the game you can
play Rook to C2 but um I mean wh white
has a uh a big variety of options like
Rook to B1 check you can't go back to B1
you can't go uh to the G file you have
to play King to E2 and then just Queen
captures on e4 check King to D2 Rook to
D1 a nice um sacrifice and after uh King
captures Queen T1 will be Checkmate as
The Rook on C2 made it possible so of
course leavon had enough of this and um
yeah I think he even lost on time here
Vincent had 13 seconds on the clock and
Al Leon really uh it took all of his
time
to to come up with a defense it's just
that there wasn't one so incredible
incredible play by by Young Vincent here
and The Rook captures on F3 while
perhaps not objectively the the
strongest move uh I mean it's it it
truly is impossible to defend like when
I say it's possible to defend when the
engine defends that's not that's not
what a human can defend especially not
in a rapid game in classical maybe you
you hold it if you're like having the
the best day possible but other than
that no sir uh so yeah that's the game
brilliantly done by by Vincent taking
down a former 2800 U you know in in a
class basically you know like no other
Leon arunan so uh congratulations on
that and U yeah we'll see uh what
happens and how Vincent will do uh in in
next run in division one uh so I would
like to thank Jeremy anos Carl Weinberg
rajash churi brianstone and David
gasparian for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens uh in the Chess World uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day